[Music]
one of the most important themes
structuring the narrative world of a
wizard of earth see and indeed all of
the other earth sea novels and stories
is that of the true name and so what
we're talking about here
is how language is understood and how
language
connects up with the world but also with
our
own selves whether we have power over
things whether
names and words and designations are
merely arbitrary or whether they get to
the
heart of things as we're going to see
for example much later on in the work
when ged tells his his friend vetch you
know your sister is like a little minnow
and vetch says to him
wow you're really a true mage because
her name in the true speech is indeed
that of minnow
and of course gad says you probably
shouldn't have revealed that to me buddy
because names are incredibly
private and personal because of their
connection
to power and one of the fitting places
to begin
is actually when ged is in the isolate
tower studying these long lists of names
we see dead sides sometimes but he did
not complain he saw that in this dusty
and fathomless matter of learning the
true name of every place thing and being
the power he wanted lay like a jewel
at the bottom of a dry well why
for magic consists in this
the true naming of a thing
so the master had said to them once
their first night in the tower he never
repeated it
but gad did not forget his words and
we're going to come back to that in in
just a moment because there's a very
important
lesson being conveyed there
so naming is incredibly important and as
you know before le guin actually writes
a wizard of earth see she writes another
short story set in earthsea called the
rule of names which is worth checking
out as well so what is a true name
it's a name in
a language that is not
known to most human beings
but is in fact spoken by the dragons who
never abandoned
that language it is the original
language
of earthsea called the
true speech or the
old speech as opposed to the hardik
language which is descended from the old
speech which is what most of the
inhabitants of the archipelago speak
although there are some islands where
they speak other things
the kargish people have their own
language as well which is disconnected
from that they took a different path as
we'll find out in later
novels but this idea of of the true
speech is particularly
important and we get a lot of important
depictions of this so
there's a discussion of this in that
very uh
lesson chapter right um and this is what
uh kurum karmak has said to to them many
a mage of great power has spent his
whole life to find out the name of one
single thing one single lost or hidden
name and still the lists are not
finished nor will they be till worlds
end
listen and you will see why in the world
under the sun and in the other world
that has no sun there is much that has
nothing to do with men and men's speech
and there are powers beyond our power
but magic
true magic is worked only by those
beings who speak the heartache tongue of
earth see or the old speech from which
it grew this is the language that
dragons speak and the language segue
spoke who made the islands of the world
and the language of our lays and songs
spells enchantments and invocations its
words lie hidden and changed among our
heartic words and now he gives some
examples of how this works
we call the foam on waves sukiyan that
word is made from two words of the old
speech
such feather and inian the sea feather
of the sea is foam he's talking about a
metaphor there right
but you cannot charm the foam calling it
sukian
you must use its own true name in the
old speech which is
essa a third
word a third thing not a metaphor but
the genuine
name
any witch he says knows a few of these
words in the old speech and a mage knows
many but there are many more and some
have been lost over the ages some have
been hidden some are known only to
dragons and to the old powers of the
earth and some are known to no living
creature and no man could learn them all
for there is
no end to that language
sometimes it feels like our own language
doesn't have any sort of end to it
english has one of the largest lexicons
of world languages but even so there
must be a finitude to it this is an
assertion that no there isn't because
the world itself and every portion of it
is named within this old speech so
language and being
and thought you could say
are connected with each other in the old
speech in a way
different than what we're used to in our
own language
and this this notion of names
things that apply to particular things
whether they be generic like you know to
the otak you know uh or
to
you know types of
birds
or
particular to a single body of water
a single stem
a person
all of these are
names and like you said the names are
known to
sentient beings like human beings to
dragons to the old powers of the earth
one of which we're going to get
introduced to in this book
some of them are known to none no living
creatures at this time but everything
has its name and
knowing the name
speaking the name
gives one power so this is why
we've got this dictum here
magic consists in this the true naming
of a
thing
and we get a really interesting
discussion about this earlier when ged
is talking to the master hand he's
learning all these ways of making things
look like other things seeming right and
he says
these charms are much the same knowing
one you know them all as soon as the
spell weaving ceases the illusion
vanishes if i make a pebble into a
diamond and he did so with a word and
flick of his wrist what must i do to
make that diamond remain diamond how is
the changing spell locked and made to
last
the master hand looked at the jewel that
glittered on ged's palm bright as the
prize of a dragon's horde
the old master murmured one word tolk
and there lay the pebble no jewel but a
rough gray bit of rock so you see he has
power over he can
change it back into
what it actually is or remove the
seeming the illusion
he says this is a rock tolk in the old
in the true speech
a bit of the stone of which rogue isle
is made a little bit of the dry land on
which men live
it is itself it is part of the world by
the illusion change you can make it look
like a diamond or a flower or a fly or
an eye or a flame
the rock flickered from shape to shape
as he named them and returned to rock
but that is mere seeming illusion fools
the beholder's senses it makes him see
and hear and feel that a thing has
changed but it does not change the thing
to change this rock into a jewel
you must change
its true
name
changing the name
changes the thing
and there's a danger involved in this he
said
it can be done
to do that my son even just so small
scrap of the world is to change the
world it can be done indeed it can be
done it is the art of the master changer
and you will learn it when you're ready
to learn it
but you must not change one thing one
pebble one grain of sand until you know
what good and evil will follow
on that act
he says iraq is a good thing if the
isles adversity were made of diamond
we'd lead a hard life here
and so this is a quite an important
lesson which is going to lead to
discussion of the equilibrium which is a
whole other
topic but
it is possible to change
the nature of things indeed that is what
happens when a mage
changes himself into a falcon or into a
dragon or a bear as we learn about a
terrible story
so how do we acquire these names
what's involved there we see at the very
beginning that you can learn names from
other people
and this is in fact what is happening uh
when when gad himself
is um
learning from his aunt i'm gonna read
this a little bit
a sister of his dead mother lived in the
village she'd done what was needful for
him as a baby but she had business of
her own and once he could look after
himself he she paid no more heed to him
but one day when the boy was seven years
old untaught and knowing nothing of the
arts and powers that are in the world he
heard his aunt crying out words to a
goat which it jumped up on the thatch of
a hut and would not come down
but it came jumping down when she cried
a certain rhyme to it
next day herding the long-haired goats
on the medals of high fall
dunny shouted to them the words he'd
heard not knowing their use or meaning
or what kind of words they were no
thirth malkmann hilthan merkhan he held
the rhyme aloud and the goats came to
him they came very quickly all of them
together not making any sound they
looked at him out of the dark slot in
their yellow eyes he laughed and
shattered it again the rhyme that gave
him power
over the goats they came closer crowding
and pushing around him and she
eventually comes and then you know
dispels the spell
he's learned
some of the true names some of the old
speech
or true speech
by listening to her and then she says
well
i'm gonna have to teach this kid and of
course she's got some screwed up ideas
herself but she says to him hey would
you like to learn
some other
names that will do things she says
she might teach him rhymes he would like
better such as the word that makes a
snail look out of its shell or the name
that calls a falcon down from the sky i
teach me that name he said being clear
over the freight the goats had given him
the witch said to him you will not ever
tell that word to the other children if
i teach it to you i promise
she smiled at his ready ignorance well
and good but i will bind your promise
your tongue will be stilled until i
choose to unbind it then even then even
though you can speak you will not be
able to speak the word i teach you where
another person can hear it we must keep
the secrets of our craft and then she
tries to bind him it doesn't actually
work and
here we see this was dunny's first step
on the way he was to follow all of his
life the way of majory
but those first steps along the way it
seemed a broad bright road when he found
the wild falcon stooped down to him from
the wind when he summoned them by name
lighting with a thunder of wings on his
wrist like the hunting bird of a prince
then he hungered to know more names and
came to his aunt begging to learn the
name of the sparrowhawk and the osprey
and the eagle to earn the words of power
he did all the which asked of him and
learned all she taught though not all of
it was pleasant to know or
do she's not a black sorceress as we
find out but she's kind of a you know a
goofball in some some respects and so
you can learn in that way right and you
can learn from all sorts of people in
that way
we also find him learning in a much more
structured way in the passage that i
read earlier from the master namer on
rogue which involves being in the
isolate tower and copying out these
lists
of names which seems like an incredibly
boring thing to do
right he was sent with seven boys across
rock island to the farthest northmost
cape where stands the isil tower
there by himself liv the master name or
who is called by a name that had no
meaning in any language
the amongst here we go uh
grimace stood above the northern cliffs
graver the clouds over the seas of
winter endless the links the lists and
ranks and rounds of names that the
namers eight pupils must learn and so
students must learn before midnight the
name of every cape point base sound
inlet channel harbor shallows reef and
rock of the shores of lasso a little
eyelet of the pillar sea if the student
complained the master might say nothing
but lengthen the list
or he might say who he who would be
seamaster must know the true name of
every drop of water in the sea so what's
going on here is this exhaustive
activity of memorizing the names not
only of general things but a very
specific things why because that's
that's very important to do
another mode of learning the names of
things
is modeled by that of ogeon the mage of
god with whom ged
does a first apprenticeship right
and so what we find is that he um
he's told by ojun it's almost like you
know the movie karate kid where daniel
is doing you know paint the fence and
and
buff the car and all that and turns out
he's learning karate so
get is learning who from ogian
so he says when will my apprenticeship
begin sir ojn says it has begun there
was a silence
then ged says but i haven't learned
anything yet
because you haven't found out what i'm
teaching replied the mage
he was a dark man like most gantischmann
dark copper brown gray-haired lean and
tough as a hound tireless he spoke
seldom ate less slept less his eyes and
ears were very keen and often there was
a listening look on his face that's very
important
you want to work spells oh jion said
presently you've drawn too much water
from that well wait manhood is patience
mastery is nine times patience what is
that herb by the path
straw flower
and that i don't know
for foil they call it ogen had halted
the copper shot foot of his staff near
the little weed so ged looked closely at
the plant and plucked a dry seed pod
from it and finally asked since ojin
said nothing more what is its use master
none i know of
god kept the seed pod a while as they
went on then tossed it away
here's the key point
when you know the forfoil in all its
seasons root and leaf and flower by
sight and scent and seed
then you may learn its true name
knowing its being which is more than its
use
what after all is the use of you or of
myself is gaunt mountain useful or the
open sea
to here one must be
silent
so
ogian is teaching him to learn what the
true names of things are which can only
be done
by a sort of
receptivity
on the part of the mage
listening
attending to
waiting
until the names
reveal themselves
names are also given to human beings and
this is something that's absolutely key
to the
we could call it the anthropology
of the archipelago
you have a name that's given to you as a
child as
our main character is with duni right
he also has a kind of nickname that will
become his public name
sparrowhawk he might be given other
names in other places when he shows up
and people give them a name for example
in the story the rule of names preceding
this the you know descendant of the
lords of pandora is called blackbeard
because he's got a black beard right mr
underhill he lives under a hill so these
are those sorts of names
and then you have the true name that is
given to you and ged's true name ged is
given to him by ogian the mage and as a
matter of fact there's a wonderful
passage
later on where ged has flown away
and manages to make it there as a hawk
o.j on the silent had come home late to
ray alby from his autumn
wanderings more silent more solitary
than ever he had become as the years
went on
the morning after his return he rose
late and wanting a cup of rush wash tea
went out to fetch water from the spring
a great hawk came down with loud beating
wings and lighted on his whisk like a
trained hunting bird it clung there but
it bore no broken leash nor banned nor
bell the claws dug hard in ogian's wrist
the barred wings trembled the round gold
eye was dull and wild
are you messenger or message ojn said
gently to the hawk come on with me
as he spoke the hawk looked at him orgin
was silent a minute
i named you once i think
he said then strode to his house and
entered bearing the bird still on his
risk on his wrist he made the hawk stand
on the hearth and the fire's heat and
after it water it would not drink then
ogin began a spell
very quietly weaving the web of magic
with his hands more than with words when
the spell was whole and woven he said
softly
ged not looking at the falcon on the
hearth he waited some while then turned
and got up then went to the young man
who stood trembling and dull-eyed before
the fire
he's able to
untransform gad from the form that he
took on perhaps too long of the falcon
so this is very important
human beings knowing their names if you
have somebody's name you have power over
them
and this is displayed
also in trust in
love in
a reliance on other people to give
somebody else
your name is a sign that you are
becoming
vulnerable to them and this is indeed
what happens when ged's friend
vetch gives to him
his name estario actually as i mentioned
it start estario's a little bit loose
with names when it comes to ged telling
of his sister's name as well
without her permission
towards the end of the book
and then ged gives estario
his name as well this is a sign of
intimacy of trust of a bond the last
thing that we have to touch upon
that plays an important role here
we even
weaving throughout the entire thing is
ged's own name and the shadows name does
the shadow actually
have a name the arc mage suggests that
it comes from a place where there are no
names and therefore it can't be named
ged has
promises from the the stone and from the
dragon that this shadow could in fact be
named we find that the shadow knows
ged's name and therefore get is not able
to work any magic against it and is
vulnerable to it as well and has to try
to flee
from it leaving behind unfortunately his
little friend the otak
to die
in the end it turns out that the shadow
does have a name but we'll leave that
for a moment so this is really
an absolutely central feature of
earthsea we have names of things we have
names of people dragons have names
everything has a name a word for it in
the true or the
old speech by which
the entire
archipelago of earthsea was brought
out of the waters
in the beginning
you